this is the tallest ramp in the entire
world
this ramp is 90 degrees this ramp looks
funny we're gonna ride down
every single one of these and do you
guys know why i asked you to bring your
friend
no why whichever one of you travels the
furthest your friend gets
twenty thousand dollars chris drive down
this ramp as fast as you can
all right keep driving boosting there we
go there we go
oh i see him nice nice nice nice nice
boom chris you traveled 511 meters
carl chandler last one down to rotten
egg i'm not a rotten egg i'll tell you
that
oh no he launched you forward he lost
you forward he cheated
he sucked you hit me you're in my way go
go go go go go
are you kidding me 369. chris is
currently in first place this ramp we
added some speed boost a giant tire and
made it steeper
yo don't hit the log don't hit the log
let's go let's go
oh nice here we go here we go here we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
strategy carl strategy through the tires
let's go
nice let's go all right 200.
chris's snow first carl's in second
chandler's in third if carl wouldn't
have sabotaged the first round we would
be winning
gentlemen this next ramp is a little
crazy go
to the moon carl to the moon
and here's the loop-de-loop loop-de-loop
control nice control nice control
nice control there we go there we go
what just happened to my car yeah let's
go i'm in first let's go let's go
first you got it all right chandler's
first let's go
carl oh my god oh carl you're killing
this
let's go come on
keep going keep going boom it doesn't
there's no vote no boost oh okay
249. wait chris you can't just drive
back up the ramp
if i'm able to i can yeah come on baby
distance
dang he beat us what you're such a
cheater you guys can get mad at me all
you want but this is for e bob
chris put it over your head you went
downstairs then backup sees that's not
allowed
to be fair i didn't know who cares go
everybody
go yeah buddy
oh you got it together get it together
no way bro we gotta get a retry just
drive forward
just drive forward no he hit you
you're a cheater what happened
green sabotaging it's not salad
how did you guys not get crushed chris
we beat chandler
what i genuinely couldn't see a thing
yeah we're still in the lead
we just got wind chop this deck strap
has tons of obstacles if you survive the
ramp you'll see a bunch of bowling pins
if you hit those bowling pins i'll give
you an extra hundred points go
i need a hundred points we need a
thousand hundred is money
let's win this money okay
okay yep straight through straight
through straight through yes yes yes yes
come on
baby oh yeah
[Music]
carl whoa here we go we bout to beat him
oh i went
way too far
oh oh both of you missed let's do this
let's do this get the bowling pins
okay all right okay this you tried carl
carl you barely like traveled at all
it's because i hit a freaking
carl we're in last place where are we in
second place bro this is the tallest
mountain
in all of gta v that's large and we put
a ramp on it go oh let's go go go go go
go
oh shut up front flip nice control nice
control
gentler get off of
carl what are you doing carl whoa
why are you so good all i used to do is
play this game
oh easy
oh come on
gentlemen i'm gonna let you redo this
jump don't hit each other
go control yeah
let's go let's go
that's my teammate
all right all right okay come on don't
hit me no yes
we're good yes yes yes taylor get
control
you can do a trailer you can do it no no
no no no no no no
yeah keep going here's the real ramp
baby
go go go go go go
this ramp is at world height it is
insane i want you all to go at the same
time
go go go go go go girl let's go let's go
let's go so it starts with the
loop-de-loop and then straight down
go go go upwards i can't see oh my gosh
this is it don't call to come back
what is this no where are you going oh
send it carl send it sandy carl boom all
three boys are now in the air
but we got him bro
oh oh chandler with the not so graceful
[Music]
landing
for this next ramp your friends are
doing it oh
you gonna say oh you good man okay go
whoa
tariq i'm gonna be so pissed at you all
right keep correcting it you're fine go
oh you're in
boost
all right wait till you get in the air i
hit it not that much down oh no
you guys are so bad oh
how did they do that that was good yeah
that was good that was close that was
all right
i'm currently so high up i'm on the edge
of space wow
there's literally nothing up here except
this giant ramp pointing down to earth
chris i'm gonna need you to go down
backwards you're just destroying them
too much man yeah i was going to slam
into them all right now you guys go
everyone go go carl go
let's go let's go let's go
no no you got it you got it you got it
carl i just got to get back on track
yeah you're good you're good
i love losing money baby
all right here comes the windmills here
comes the windmills oh she's got a
missile
oh oh green it's doing good go go go go
go go go go
send it oh my gosh carla's going full
gamer right now
i'm trying so hard to go backwards why
i'm just spinning
no what the hell this is so hard this is
harder than just normal
now you can turn around there you go
yeah yeah
he still made it fun
i'm just so much better than everyone
this next ramp you go through the tire
than the drop it's pretty scary
carl and chandler buddies chris is at
the very back he's really far
you guys can go whenever i'd recommend
your team or you could just go chandler
i'm going
go let's go bro oh no
no bro that's cheating
oh oh wait chris what just happened
don't worry don't worry i got it don't
worry i got it i had it
oh
so both chandler and chris didn't even
make it off the ramp on this one
i can't believe how unlucky i actually
am and now
time for the largest ramp in the entire
world
it go down let's do this all right
chris is in first place chandler and
carl are basically tied for second
this is an anything goes rules you can
hit each other you can do whatever you
want
gentlemen decide who gets 20
so fast 20 mcflurries
20 pounds 20 000 20 000 let's go
all the boys are now in the air
1300 meters baby
let's go bro you won this oh you're
still
oh day and tariq i hate to break the
news to you
but ethan just won 20 thousand dollars
that was close if you feel bad for tariq
watch this video he gets paid every time
someone does and if you feel bad for zay
i don't know the video ended